this week we've got wealthy fancy stolen
tuition and karate mall brawl
I like that one that sounds awesome
well we're not gonna go in that order
the order that I want yes all right so
for the first story rihanna is named the
world's wealthiest female musician all
for Beyonce more than fair lady all more
than Adele bro oh she's not mentioned
Madonna's the other 100 Rihanna she is
now worth 600 million dollars her line
how is Kylie's still worth more Kylie's
in the building that's where makeup
dance I'm thinking as an artist you
might not make more as much as the
production over the publishing house or
like the company so if it's unless you
own it yourself
like Michael Jackson yeah he owned a lot
of publishing so dude any owned other
songs
dude he owned like 50 or 60% of Sony's
like catalogue and the Beatles can look
yeah Wow so Rihanna
according to Forbes over its overtaking
Madonna by 30 million Celine Dion by a
hundred and fifty million and Beyonce by
200 million whoa I'm just glad that she
would beat Madonna cause it's [ __ ] I
hate Madonna why what do you know about
her dude no it's that she's such a [ __ ]
all the time like like have you ever
seen that video of her some fan comes at
her and gives her flowers and then he
walks away and she's like I love
hydrangeas really it's a [ __ ] dude and
she uses a fake London accent cuz she
lived there for like 18 weeks or
something she's pretty [ __ ] nuts
yeah she's out of her mind but she's a
[ __ ] of a live performer dude she's
incredible you've seen that no she's
she's an energetic gram I see videos of
her live and and just know that she can
do that for three hours and sing and
dance and being 70 right I don't know if
she's 70 or not she wasn't such a big
see to people so Rihanna here how are
you looking like that Mommy
you guys know Jays
he's a billionaire no I did know that
it's [ __ ] tight I think it was
released this week yeah yeah I'm just
glad that Dre beat him you know like
jay-z them no no I like Dre more so
they're saying here that Rihanna is
because she has her fancy beauty her
lingerie label savage ex venti and then
she also now has created her own fashion
label called fenty they're saying that
the majority of her income comes from
her partnership with LVMH which is a
French luxury goods company that owns
Christian Dior Givenchy conglomerate
mm-hmm yeah and so they she is the first
black woman to create an original label
with LVMH trying to be like one of those
big fashion houses luxury fashion houses
which is cool yeah but then people a lot
of these people make money off of
products not even what their music or
anything that they started with dude
look at Jessica Alba like acting is like
a [ __ ] song and a window to her do it
like like compared to what she's making
now like they're business savvy
afterwards is what's so crazy what is
this little baby products Oh baby was it
that honest okay yeah and I think it's
like five hundred million dollars I'm
sure like that do you know well fenty
Beauty there Forbes is estimating that
it's worth more than three billion but
Rihanna they're estimating that she has
it the stake is about 15% so the
majority is LVMH who owns it but that's
still a lot of money you're complaining
about like well the prices are too high
[ __ ] this is a [ __ ] luxury house
just like complaining about a Rolex yeah
shut the [ __ ] up he can't don't complain
about things you can't afford do so
she's got a luxury house collection
fashion house yeah oh my god dude I am a
[ __ ] idiot oh yeah you are I was like
he's at home you know like yes you are
Steve drew I was like this chick has
like just selling houses mega mansions
associate holds a bunch of mail that's
dope that they're your thoughts were
that I I guess I thought just so much
better of her
but that's like she's the [ __ ] 600
millionaire in here not a good point
yeah well I mean her Fenty like her
cosmetics line is just as cute it looks
dope though what were you trying to say
that her cosmetics line has 40
foundation shades and that her lingerie
line has been applauded for catering to
a range of skin tones and body types and
that her fashion line caters to women up
to size 14 so like she's just like
that's why her fenty thing is so huge
because she's catering to so many women
she's all about like women she's saying
that women are forces of this earth we
are multifaceted and they shop like
crazy and Fanty speaks to all of our
intricacies I wish I had a women fanbase
so that the problem with the brands was
that all these brands would make like
all these foundations but it was for
like there's only like white girls and
like two shades for black wood yeah
they're like people yeah how come she
only makes it up to size 14 she's like
[ __ ] size 15 people I go to 16 wait so
there's 16 sizes at all no I think
there's more I don't know no there's
those my twenty-something like so it's
like a black owned company that doesn't
cater any products to black people and
that's the controversy no no it caters
to skin type you know she's just so so
originally the company's all they would
do is like create like six shades so
that they can fit all like the women in
all our color types right but we're like
there's more than six shades on this
[ __ ] planet women of color yeah so
then Rihanna created Fenty and created
so many different shades to cater to so
she filled a void huge no one was
supplying cosmetics for the different
shades of brown in her lingerie to like
there's a range skin tones like nude is
for wiper white nude like yeah new
doesn't even look new there's it was
this big issue like there was a lot of
brands who would like release shades and
there's like for black girls it was like
light you know there wasn't nude looks
like grocery bag to me your your paper
man I see but there was like no shades
for dark-skinned black people you know
lowball black stockings no for makeup
this is just like the color black you
know like there's nothing that matches I
think black is so sexy though blacks my
favorite alright moving on to the next
story these two Chinese college students
allegedly used stolen credit cards to
pay their tuition doing crime but it's
still for school what does that say
about our education system University of
New Hampshire students man I feel bad
for the college students today man you
have to pay so much money and their
degree is worth [ __ ] I heard that if you
moved to I found out which country it
was but if you go there like you get to
go to school for free Norway was it
Norway like a lot of people a lot of
Scandinavian country read something
about foreign students can go to school
for free I think it was Germany Norway
does that no I like it was a different
one well you can't just [ __ ] move
there and go hey I'm moving to Germany
now and I'm gonna go to school for free
don't you have to like go through a
process work Mesa yeah no you have to be
a citizen talking about no I'm saying
but isn't there like a process you can't
just like show up me like yo the other
thing I read about that is that they
also hold like all the school I mean
classes are in English if you know
English you could go I think it was
Germany I forgot but it's free but
anyway so yeah these students here they
used stolen credit cards from the entire
country and also Australia so Texas
California Virginia Florida New Jersey
Wisconsin and Australia and they were
trying to pay over fifty six thousand
dollars to the college with these credit
cards that's crazy
yeah it was flagged by the school were
they good students though that's what
good students you you can't Church 56
grand on credit cards and be smart okay
for the tuition because it's 56 K no no
that's what I'm saying now you charge
that showing like two cards they charge
on like twenty cards you have to be a
criminal go to school in America it's
been great oh [ __ ] great yeah so
they're saying that they were contacted
by this unknown person via text offering
to pay for their college at a discount
and so they sent money to the
pursed they're saying that they sent
money to this person and then that later
they received a notice that their
tuition hadn't been paid and that they
were unaware that stolen cards were used
to cover the tuition and also a traffic
fine
oh they're saying that that third person
the police [ __ ] did you trust with money
Legrand that's a made-up person what
they did is they stole credit cards
online and they just got caught for it
yeah do they use it to pay for like
their identities I love it oh he has an
Asian fro are they brothers Wow wait it
might be the same guys they don't have
the same last name Oh what damn I told
you these and jeans are strongest [ __ ]
they just damn get the same for hun care
what the [ __ ] that looks like the same
they just both look like rice gum tired
rice gum oh they do no I want to keep
looking at rice come that's not the same
person Alyssa they're related for sure
yeah are they not like why oh yeah one
got curly hair I mean but they come up
relate they can look related they do
know like and why it's like evil twins
how come they both look like they just
got into a fight - I know they do they
just got done crying mm-hmm
Oh guys I know that's crazy they did
some shady [ __ ] for court education dude
get to [ __ ] steal money to go to
school that's sad a lot of people still
money to do noble ish things for
themselves like Robin Hood style
well like oh it's like I need to pay my
rent I'm gonna steal some [ __ ] like gran
is okay nobody think about if you got a
kid or something in a way yeah like it's
like you know becomes a little more
noble sounding but this is more like
basically this just sounds like hella
pressure from their families and they're
like [ __ ] we got to do it we're gonna
get [ __ ] this just sounds like I don't
want to even it's like you steal for
rewards this ain't even a reward
no how do colleges know that you're not
just dropping in on classes all the time
that's what I wondered - oh but they
don't take role it's actually hundred
people what I just walked in yeah you
know cuz you're not gonna get your
diploma then you
you yes so couldn't you get a free
education no just like showing up a
little hard tip-off there folks piece of
paper and the credentials to say that
you wouldn't like that's what people
that's no I know that's the real value I
know that only learn some [ __ ] you learn
a ton so like let's say you want to
become a lawyer so you have to take the
bar in order to be before you become a
lawyer but what if you just go to all
the classes that's a little bit harder
graduate school classes are way smaller
they probably take roll if you're like
one undergrad and there's like three
hundred students they're not gonna know
who's there who's not yeah do you get a
[ __ ] free Lobby well you know MIT
they do have free like a little [ __ ] ton
of free things that you can learn on
their website that's pretty cool dude
you go to these classes for free then
you pass the bar and you're in do you
need a lot of green MIT OpenCourseWare
you might have to have bachelor's or
something I'm not sure but it doesn't
have to be in law a lot of stuff too now
the requirements went up for like now
you need master's for certain things or
like I think to get a CPA you have to
have a master's along with certain
credits and tests and stuff or like
physical therapists it used to be
bachelors now it's masters so just the
standards are going up that's true so
like a [ __ ] time man I feel bad for
students all right you guys got a rough
man yeah so now of these guys one of
them faces nine felony accounts of fraud
mmm well the other one was slept with
one felony and one misdemeanor charge
for attempted fraud both students they
pleaded not guilty and have been
released on a $5,000 bail somebody tried
to pay for my school I would do the same
[ __ ] I would just try to jump on a plane
and go back to China that's how much
they don't like China last story here
Chinese shopping mall brawl breaks out
between Taekwondo school and then that's
a movie and gym stuffy gym like Lifan
wait what happened yes dog they're
saying that this Taekwondo people they
were seen giving him a demonstration to
promote their school but they were being
too loud which led to noise come from
hi guys are too loud man
yeah and so they were confronted by a
group of employees from a gym that's
inside that same mall and then an
argument broke out and now let me show
you the video hell yeah
the pipe talk [ __ ] what's this [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] [ __ ] don't work and instead oh yeah
lit up crazy kick or something yes so
the lesson is to go to the gym yeah yeah
that one's getting clocked the lessons
forms are bullshitting blows man they're
all they're all up in there like some
business that Jim's even gone to
business after this video comes out why
would they go on a business the gym
works that's right the dojo is going cuz
what better publicity than the Taekwondo
guys meaning you know then it's like
come to our play that's why forms are
[ __ ] dude I said that when I was a
kid in Taekwondo I was like this is such
[ __ ] I wear just one one how to
fight people if you watch the video
they're not using any Taekwondo there's
like a guy that's just [ __ ] brawling
like what if it was their first class
their black belt let's start a class to
teach like just dirty street fighting
bas Rutten spam you just like put sand
in your pockets you can throw it in
their eyes and you walk around the
neighborhood with sand in your pocket
yeah that's like that's like club [ __ ]
fighting is what you this perfect I love
it teach someone I [ __ ] break a glass
and shove someone to the jugular man mmm
the real fighting I don't want to break
a glass and then hurt myself the reason
why it's hi cuando guys were on the
floor is because like they're trying to
get the gym staff in trouble paper
faking it like we're fake they're
supposed to be honorable
yeah these that were to lock they were
flopping Oh marshal I supposed to be
honourable what the [ __ ] do I love if
you probably turn the camera around in
their windows they honor tradition
strength [ __ ] job dollars [ __ ] oh
that's because it's a Taekwondo school
in China it's probably not even real
Taekwondo dude it's probably some just
old Asian do this once make money oh I
knew all those forms and [ __ ] I don't do
it all that [ __ ] that's so boring yeah
so they're saying like some people are
commenting like they were laying down
probably for the lawyers so they could
take the fight to court they can't even
win that fight how hypocritical this
group is yeah that's so [ __ ] fine
going to cordon be like we got our asses
beat like that's what we can prove it
like damn that's bad not one Jim dude
with a black shirt was beating the [ __ ]
good funny because what if the the dojo
or the type of the owner was sitting at
home and he sees this video and just
makes him look bad like dude [ __ ] you
guys doing you know right this threw his
honour out the window the owner should
sue all those kids for defamation well
if they're all Chinese they're gonna be
like that's right let's get all that's
true he's like he's proud of honor
doesn't exist there I know but yeah so
that was going around cuz it's so
[ __ ] fighting it's like 100 versus
gems
the irony is [ __ ] dull amazing dude
in that the gym staff they look kind of
like Jack - I was like damn man what are
they
it was a lot of them look like they
fought way better
therefore I'm like clay can you play it
again you'll see this one guy throwing
some mad [ __ ] blood donors like whole
body into it yeah it doesn't really good
oh yeah oh oh oh my god the best part
that's the best part
I bet you they're [ __ ] master was
like we're gonna use deception stay on
the whole hook yet stay down play possum
why that guy look like basketball Bart's
character in the back with the red vest
oh yeah
they're all black box right not brown
belts was that character basketball
wasn't me yeah name was basketball
another guy different wines similar one
just really dumb ones even dumber yeah
[Music]